[Music]
you the only person i ever met
belonged in the sky
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer called you one of
the best pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being the naval aviator
absolutely
the whole world's looking different do
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored aviator
lieutenant tom hudner jesse brown
it's good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you gonna find out about your
wingman cruising at 10 000 feet
lieutenant
put him in a little bit of trouble who
knows you might get a peek at who he
really is
the north koreans came pouring over the
38th parallel
our guys need help
and we're up
we knew this day might come
and it doesn't make it any easier
the most important thing is this
we bring everyone
home
mistakes get us killed
i can't tell you how many times people
have told me to give up quickly
die even
[Music]
if i did
i wouldn't be here
what do you want me to do just be my
wing man
[Applause]
the real battle in all of life
is being someone that people can count
on
show off that was pretty good it's good